[Music]
trevor is in new york city hi trevor
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave hey george happy bestseller day
thank you sir we appreciate that yeah
how can we help today
yeah so i have a question regarding uh
my
student loan i took out probably about
seven years ago um i i went to college
when uh wasn't able to do it without
taking out loans but obviously now i
wish i could have but um
back in uh that time we had a co-signer
go on to that loan it was uh a family
member um they didn't really want to do
it and it proved to kind of be like a
point of contention and
nothing bad ever happened with it so far
and now that i'm in baby step two fast
forward to today
um i've been paying off uh all that
all my loan snowball style and
my question is being that that's kind of
part of my why i recently received a
cosign release application for that loan
um and i was curious what you guys
thought about if i should
go ahead and act on that cosigner
release why are they offering to release
the co-signer i've never heard of that
because it's been a certain amount of
time since um i've been paying on the
loan now for like two to three years
um so after
i think it's 24 months they offer you to
be able to drop them as a co-signer drop
them
why wouldn't you okay
because that's kind of part of my why as
to why i want to pay it off and like
it's kind of giving me my intensity to
go hardcore
um
so in essence like i could take them off
but then i also feel like that would
kind of halt my progress a little bit my
motivation why would it halt the
progress what's the motivation behind
having the co-signer on there
because by having them on there it makes
me want to pay it off even more
to prove to them that it was possible to
start with and that it was uh
it was a i know it wasn't a good
decision at the time but that i was
trustworthy with that decision yeah um
the student loan is not going to do that
you're going to do that with the way you
live your life
the you know you're trying to you're
trying to make the student loan work too
hard in this relationship
it doesn't have the ability it does not
have the ability to make this person
respect you
yeah so no i'm i'm rea
i i i think you can manage your own
motivation the fact that you can ask the
question tells me that you can manage
your own motivation
and uh you need to let them go as soon
as possible for their sake your sake the
sake of the relationship plus there's no
point in having them on there i mean it
lowers the risk of the overall situation
i love it yeah i get rid of them
definitely yeah i didn't even know they
did this i've never heard of it so
that's awesome yeah
yeah
um yeah because i figured it'll be paid
off within the next year and a half
anyway but um
release them and then you just be uh you
just man up and say all right i gave up
my
bitterness motivation so i have to have
a new motivation
yeah a more positive one let's just get
a noble one that's not me pissed off at
somebody and i'll show you if anything's
going to show them it's you removing
them as a co-signer well that means
now that just lets him go it doesn't
show that he's reliable sure to his
point but
but you know that uh
yeah find something else to motivate you
that was my instinct was you need a
bigger why then the chip on the shoulder
yeah the family that's it that was it
that's it but i love the spirit of it
the intensity you've got to pay this
thing off but don't let the family
member be the motivation you need a
bigger why man you got to do it for
yourself
yeah i mean if they can't look at you
and say look you know trevor paid off
all his loans while he was doing it he
let me off
and
gosh i always wondered if he was going
to do it and he did it he and it proved
it if they can't do that
without being a co-signer they can't do
it while they are a co-center yeah
they're just going to be that guy
they're just going to be the twerp the
rest of whoever this is they're just
going to be a twerp and so
that you know you're asking the student
loan to
give you the power to make them respect
you and it does not give you that power
you being you you manning up you taking
care of business it puts you in a seat
that should be respected and then it's
their choice whether they're going to do
that or not
so don't ask this situation to do that
for you uh and that that's how i would
look at it but it's a it got you started
we'll give it that but at least it got
you started good catalyst there's
nothing wrong with having a a a
little bit of a selfish or
negative reason for getting started but
then you don't keep going when i got
started i got started because i pissed
off at american express but you know i'm
still pissed off at him but it's not my
motivation yeah you know
anger is a good start but it's got to
turn into excitement about your future
there you go